where are we at with impeaching Joe
Biden over his obvious and discernible
Shady business dealings with his son
where where are we at there uh it Kevin
McCarthy said we are now going to begin
the process of beginning an inquiry into
impeachment yep
so it'll never happen so now now we're
at the point where we decided to start
the process of asking the question does
this rise the level of impeachment
which we already know it clearly does
but it's just a pony show that's really
it all it is is it's just four show it's
to give people false hope and stay home
they're fighting back oh yeah I mean he
could have been I think he could have
been impeached within his first month in
office I mean with all the evidence even
there was enough evidence with Hunter
Biden yeah if you want to make an
argument that those were pre-bidden
presidency then okay then Afghanistan
outright I mean that was such a disaster
and utter failure it warrants removal in
my opinion all the stuff that's coming
out about barisma and Ukraine and stuff
the the that's plenty of reason to
impeach